Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, this week on
the Flash we met a couple more big comic book
characters and got some more information about
the big villain.
So I’ll start with my top 5 easter eggs
then do my review and circle back around for
all the other references I spotted.
And hello any new people, if you’re just
finding me for the first time I’m doing
weekly DC and Marvel videos.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Careful for spoilers from the episode if you
haven’t seen it yet.
I’ll wait just a sec...okay, top 5 easter
eggs,
Number 5 - Barry Needs Junk Food
Anyone who saw the original Flash TV Series
with John Wesley Shipp might remember the
scene where he ate like 18 pizzas while Doctor
McGee watched him.
The way Caitlin Snow explained everything
is a lot more complex but The Flash draws
on the Speed Force to give him his power.
His body is mostly the same, he still has
to burn calories like anyone else.
He just burns a shitload more.
That’s where all the junk food comes from.
When they went back to Barry’s lab you could
see all the empty pastry boxes.
By the end of the episode Cisco had created
a crazy powerful version of a clif bar.
So I don’t think they’ll do a ton more
Junk Food jokes.
We might see him throwing away the occasional
candy bar wrapper though.
One of those energy bars he’s got is the
equivalent of 850 Tacos.
Also equal to one Chipotle Burrito.
Number 4 - We Were All Struck By That Lightning
This is a huge wink at the comics, at least
one other person in that group was probably
struck by the speed force lightning.
I won’t say who exactly just in case you
haven’t read the comics.
But Caitlin Snow and Cisco Ramon both have
super powers un-related to the lightning.
It’s unclear whether or not the show will
give them powers.
But Caitlin Snow’s alias is Killer Frost,
she has Cold based powers and Cisco’s is
Vibe, he can create shock waves.
That’s why everytime Danielle Panabaker
makes a funny face when Barry talks about
metahumans I feel like she secretly was affected
by the Star Labs explosion and just isn’t
telling them.
Number 3 - Metamorpho
Simon Stagg, the person William Sadler was
playing is directly responsible for the creation
of Metamorpho, the show isn’t doing that
character this season, and they just killed
Simon Stagg, but the whole idea of cells adapting
to become anything the body needs is a pretty
good nod.
Multiplex is a different villain in the comics,
but his powers are pretty much what you saw.
He makes copies of himself.
It seemed like he died too at the end, so
we might not see him again.
Number 2 - Captain Clone
Cisco naming super villains is probably going
to continue to be a thing which is awesome.
But Captain Clone is just a wink at Captain
Cold who we’ll meet in Episode 4.
Obviously when we see all the rogues for the
first time they’ll appear their real selves.
So we’ll be meeting Leonard Snart, not Captain
Cold.
He’s being played by Wentworth Miller from
Prison Break.
He is probably going to be the coolest villain
this season, no pun intended.
But seriously, he’s not the biggest villain.
If you watched Arrow Season 2, think of him
more as a Brother Blood level villain, like
a medium bad.
and my number 1 easter egg - Firestorm
Next week is when we’ll meet Ronnie Raymond
aka Firestorm.
It sounds like it’s going to be a flashback
to before the star labs explosion.
He’s Danielle Panabaker’s fiancee, part
of the reason she’s so angry all the time
is because he died, or she thinks he died.
The episode is called “Things You Can’t
Outrun”, which is a reference to the other
villain they’ll be chasing “Mist”.
I also think it’s a reference to a nuclear
explosion.
Like the flash can’t out run something that
devestating.
It’s just a reference to Firestorm’s Nuclear
based powers.
Hopefully we’ll get to see Robbie Amell
as Firestorm in present day.
But he’ll eventually be part of Team Flash
the same way Oliver Queen started adding people
to Team Arrow.
Very excited, I know all the Tomorrow People
fans were pumped when the cast him as a big
comic book superhero.
I already did a big explainer video for him
and for captain cold.
So I’ll add links to those in the description
if you want to learn more about those characters.
Just as a bonus WTF Comic Book Moment - Harrison
Wells, we have to talk about him.
Clearly someone sinister, if he had been a
future version of Barry he would not have
killed Stagg.
The evidence that he’s really professor
zoom is stacking up.
There’s still a chance he could be a different
version of the reverse flash.
There are many of them.
I also did a video explaining them all.
Lots of explaining going around.
So if you want to dig deeper on all these
huge characters just check the description.
Let me know though, what was your favorite
moment and do you think Harrison Wells is
Professor Zoom or do you think he’s someone
else?
Overall I gave the episode an A minus for
digging deeper into the character relationships.
All the comic book stuff is great, but that
means nothing if the characters fall flat.
Of all the relationships on the show, not
sexual relationships, the ones I’m most
interested in right now are Barry and Caitlin,
Barry and Harrison and Barry and Eddie Thawne.
Eddie Thawne isn’t really much of a character
yet.
We’ll probably get a lot more time with
him soon.
Harrison of course is throwing all the WTF
moments at us, he’s definitely obsessed
with Barry in a very time travely way.
And Caitlin Snow is probably the most complex
character on the show right now.
Which for me, makes her the most interesting.
She clearly has a lot she’s not telling
everyone.
Yet.
Cisco, Detective West and Iris West are all
totally open books.
There is nothing they are hiding.
So most of the intrigue will come from those
other characters.
The story was great, Barry realizing his limits
and everyone else realizing that as long as
Barry Believes in himself, he kind of doesn’t
have limits.
We’ll continue to learn more about the nature
of the speed force and how his powers work.
Right now he’s still using it in a relatively
unsophisticated way.
Like swirling beakers around and running around
things.
In the comics, he can vibrate his body so
fast he can pass through solid objects and
with the aid of the Star Labs jacked up treadmill.
He can travel through time.
I almost forgot, Treadmill equals cosmic treadmill
easter egg.
Be sure to let me know if you spotted any
other comic book references in the episode
that I missed.
But next week is Firestorm, prepare thyself.
I’ll post my video after the episode airs.
So be sure to subscribe to get it.
I’ll be posting my Agents of SHIELD video
wednesday morning.
So look out for that too.
And Arrow Episode 2 tomorrow night.
Right now click here for my Flash Episode
1 video and Click Here for my Arrow Episode
1 video.